and we say good morning to the Dodgers
manager the Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
Dave Roberts what's on the agenda today
in there uh Dave how you doing good
morning we've got great weather here in
Glendale Arizona almost at Camelback
Ranch and we got the Halos today later
one o'clock all right have you ever been
late I have not been late but I will say
this in spring training I should sort of
show up a little bit later than most
people do so when you go into Tempe they
they really draw well and they're sort
of one way in one way out so I have
arrived I have been known to arrive at
the ballpark after the anthem which is
in a good feeling let's get to the
serious questions here at what point do
you make a decision on who your opening
day starter is I think it'll probably be
in the coming days soon
obviously we nameplate you which was a
no-brainer is our number was our opening
day starter pushed back a little bit
with the arm and so now he's out to 120
letting it rip feels good but obviously
when you could even work backward from
opening day there's a build up that has
to take place so we're cutting it pretty
close right now but regardless Dan the
most important thing is playing to be
ready at some point during the early
part of the season but you think right
now that that's that's the plan that
he's going to start opening day well
that's the plan but you know and I think
that when you say that obviously when
you're talking about him potentially
going nine innings and built up to that
that's not plausible or potentially
seven innings but you know we as an
organization decide that aid to him to
take the mound to go five and seventy
five that that makes sense then that's
okay but if not and we want more of a
build up then we'll have that discussion
as well disappointment surprised the
Bryce Harper sign with the Phillies
no you know what I think that ultimately
he and his wife you know they got the
best offer and they felt you know they
wanted to go you know with that best
offer the biggest commitment 13 years so
no not a surprise at all how close do
you think it was III think that he was
really trying to kick the tires on a
couple of the ball clubs you know the
Dodgers being one and I think our
meeting went really well but ultimately
he landed where he and his family wanted
to land but and for us you know we've
got a very good ballclub as it is and
you know when you get an opportunity to
talk to a player a superstar like him it
only makes sense to do so should
baseball have a problem that Bryce is
openly recruiting Mike Trout you know I
think that I guess under the you know
the CBA it's against the rules I just
think that a lot of that stuff goes on
but I just think that he could be a
little bit more subtle but I don't
really think it's gonna affect Mike on
in one way or the other down the road
yeah I just think this is what the NBA
almost embraces this this happens every
day in the NBA where we're speculating
where Kevin Durant is gonna end up and
who LeBron can get to play if I'm
baseball even though it's awkward
uncomfortable it's something that people
are talking about people need to talk
more about baseball I just don't know if
they're going to not that this should be
the reason why but this is one of those
things that the NBA embraces no I think
that's fair
you know whenever there's banter
dialogue conversations about our
particular sport or any sport obviously
there's going to be more interest so I
think that that's a fair argument for
sure we're taking the ability to recruit
players openly yet we're talking to Dave
Roberts the Dodgers manager joining us
Dan Patrick show what's the best
conversation the funniest conversation
you ever had on the mound
oh my gosh you know I would say probably
about some some jokes somebody some
infielder might tell a joke a catcher
might tell a joke I'm not a good joke
teller so I can't recall you know
there's times in between when you're
going to go out there and you want to
pump them up take his mind off something
some type of comic relief and but
there's a lot of stuff that doesn't is
it we're not talking about baseball
which is which is a good thing yeah but
you ever gone out there and you just you
know how do you loosen somebody up who
you feel like is really tense I think
that you know I'll talk about something
off to feels something personal with
their life or something that happened in
the clubhouse that day or one of our
teammates and probably in the in past
years probably make a joke about yasiel
Puig or something like I'm looking at
I'm looking at the everyday roster and
you guys seem solid you know you got AJ
from the Diamondbacks you get Seger back
got your outfield set I'm just curious
if you're interested in some of these
pitchers who are out there you know
Dallas Keuchel I don't know if that's a
possibility or are you set do you think
right now with your roster going into
the regular season I do I do you know
we've got some serious tough decisions
going forward here in the coming weeks
but as far as you know somebody that's
free right now I just don't think that
with our pitching depth bullpens a
position player where we're at you
mentioned I just don't see us doing
anything opens opening day are you
a proponent of having a reliever start a
game do you think you'll ever get to
that point well I mean I don't you know
I think it's a possibility right now I
think that you know with the opener
these are lineups that are pretty much
set where you can kind of get an
advantage on a platoon advantage for
that first inning but I think that most
teams now we're starting to get away
from that set spot in the order for
their players and and if you look at the
Dodgers for the most part we change it
up you know JT's
two or three but for the so I'm open to
it it's part of the rules if you get
that advantage and your reliever buys
into it the starter is okay with his
routine and if it gives that event it's
great but if it doesn't work it
definitely doesn't look good
could you get tossed out of today's game
for me you know what I might try yeah I
think I could yeah I'm gonna give it my
best shot how about that okay you got
your golf clubs with you all right no
but I've got I can just move my six
o'clock dinner plans with my wife's life
call it five o'clock you show up and
she's like what are you doing here
I got tossed just go in there in your
full uniform so I can go see I can't
promise that okay I can really try to
get tossed and I can argue balls and
strikes and I'm just gonna blame you
though okay and I you don't get fine for
getting tossed in spring training
because you're gonna pay okay I will I
is is there is there a non swear word
phrase that you can use that you know
you're going to get run when you drop
you on them when you make it personal or
something like you're trying to catch a
plane or you got a dinner plan or
something like that without using
profanity that'll get you run like how
about you just say you can't even spell
strike am I gone am I your god I don't
think I'm gone oh they might laugh at me
you usually have fun today against the
Angels and always great to catch up with
you that's Dave Roberts the Dodger
manager I think he's gonna get run today
you know I think Continental Tire
Coaches Corner
proud to be the exclusive tire the Dan
Patrick show no matter what you drive
where you drive how you drive
continental designs tires for what you
do for more information visit cotton
tire calm calm tire for what you do for
more Dan Patrick show to the
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]